find the mentor if you want to have
success in whatever goal you have you're
trying to accomplish this big dream of
yours you want to get there one of the
fastest ways to do it is to find the
mentor find somebody who's gone through
it who's done it already who's achieved
what you've achieved who's figured out
all the steps and who can guide you
because they made all the mistakes I may
take in 20 years to get there you can
shortcut your path by that 20 years to 6
months with the right mentor who can
help give you the right direction I've
got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys and you
who wrote in to say hi Evan my name is
Andy first let me say that I love your
videos thank you Andy they're great and
you are truly inspiring person I'm 17
years old soon we'll be over after
school I want to start an LLP
neuro-linguistic programming and
coaching education I want to study
economics psychology everyday I'm
spending time to prepare myself for
success I read books improve my skills
get myself inspired by watching videos
like yours I think being an entrepreneur
for example starting a coaching business
would be something that extremely
fulfills me my goals and all that help
people but to build something big to
make my life a masterpiece I love this I
want to ask you there any words of
advice you could give me on the way I
really appreciate that greetings Andy
Andy I love your passion I love your
passion and you're doing all the right
things you're reading the books you're
watching the videos you're getting
inspired and you found something that
you're passionate about which is amazing
your next step my best advice for you is
go find a mentor okay
books are great keep doing it keep
watching the videos if they're with mine
inspire you great other people were
talking about NLP great keep learning
but if you want to shortcut your path to
create the successful coaching practice
go find somebody who's already doing it
who you look up to who you can learn
from when I had my first business of the
software company biotech software and
what really helped my comforting take
off was a guy named John who was our
mentor who was my mentor he helped line
up deals he helped me see where my
business could go he helped me negotiate
he helped teach me about
to run a company and to close deals and
and I read all the books and I learned
from mom in success and and you know
YouTube wasn't a huge thing at that time
didn't have the videos to look at but
having his experience helped shortcut my
path to success so dramatically and if
you want to start a coaching practice
you could try to figure it all out
yourself if you try to figure it out by
reading books and they're watching
videos and you might ask people like me
questions on how to started and you
might get some great answers but the
best help you're gonna get is watching
somebody who's done exactly what you
want to do find whoever the the best NLP
coach is hopefully there's somebody
local in your area and offer to work
with them for free because you want an
education because the information
they're gonna give you in three months
six months one year is more than then
you would get in ten years of trying to
do it yourself learn from the best offer
to help out in whatever way you can get
their vision their guidance their
inspiration the motivation learn how
they started learn how they went from
nothing to having their first client to
building up this huge movement that
they've created for themselves do that
and you will shortcut your path you're
so young you have the world ahead of you
I'm excited for the opportunities are
gonna create for yourself and that the
changes you're gonna make for this
planet go find a mentor and believe
those are you watching I'd love to hear
what you think I'd love to hear if you
found the mentor if you're searching
ferment or leave it in the comments
below I'd love to hear from you you
liked this video give it a thumbs up
below it makes you want to do more for
you and click on my face to subscribe to
the channel I'll see more videos like
this thank you so much I'll see you soon